[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Knorr I prefer to think that Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death we don't talk about death as much
anymore John I can fix that okay good
but we in addition to talking about that
we answer your questions give you
dubious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon hey John how you do it I'm
doing all right considering that the
sweet embrace of death is coming for me
yeah no forever forever and ever I so so
when you raise your children as a
question that has become very pressing
to me when do you when do you start to
tell them that they're going to die
I guess when they start asking which is
pretty early I remember
Henry's best friend Luna her cat died
and there was a whole ceremony they
buried the cat in the backyard Luna and
Henry were probably three and afterwards
someone came over to the house and said
Luna I heard your cat went to heaven and
Luna looked at the person and said what
are you talking about there's no heaven
for cats the cat went in the yard yeah
exactly the cat is under the tree and I
was just thinking like man they already
have these sophisticated ideas around
death that they just don't express to
you because they're sort of probably
because they're afraid of it like I
remember that Maurice Sendak once saying
about childhood that he knew the only
thing he knew was that he was aware of
deep and terrible secrets that adults
didn't seem to know and I do think that
children are very aware from a very
early age of the subjects that adults
are trying to tiptoe around yep all
right well that I know the answer it's
John I'll just I'll start him off early
now do you have a short poem for us
today yeah I'm glad that we've started
on such a high note how are you doing I
guess we could talk about me I'm fine I
feel really good I spent a lot of time
this weekend trying to make
all of the things that I have to do go
away which I love and I've been saying
no too many people and and I have this
wonderful reason to say no and they can
be like oh that's a great reason for you
to say no and then I don't have to worry
about hurting their feelings so it's
wonderful ya know and that that by the
way that doesn't go away like you
continue to be able to use parenthood as
an excuse so that's that that's one of
the big benefits I would argue of
parenthood in addition to the pure joy
of having children Sara and I just got
back from a one-week vacation slash
writing retreat mostly a writing retreat
in Maine which was really lovely and I
was delighted to have Flula played the
role of me last week I thought he did a
great job but I'm very happy to be back
I'm glad to have you back I'm glad to
have you back and I have to ask on
behalf of all of the people in the world
did you finish your book mm no no I did
not I am working hard okay it is
difficult and slow but mm let's answer
some questions from our listeners wait
no first I have a short short poem short
poem Hank I really liked a couple weeks
ago when you turned our corrections into
a short poem so I decided to take a
corrective note from a listener named
Jerome and turn it into a short poem by
adding line breaks it is as follows the
u.s. mint does not make any hundred
dollar bills or any bills at all for
that matter they only make coins this is
an innovation John I don't know can I do
one yes yes feel free
all right everyone on Twitter would like
you to know that it was Rick Springfield
and not Ric Ocasek who wrote Jessie's
Girl but still I stand by the fact that
Jessie's Girl was named Jessie I'm
really sorry to Rick Springfield by the
way I carried that bit on with Flula for
a long time about about Ric Ocasek
wanting Jessie's Girl Jesse but it was
Rick Springfield differ
Rick too many Rick's too many Jesse's
John and it's hard out there for a
Springfield let's move on to questions
from our listeners this one comes from
Emily who writes dear John and Hank is
there a way for me to moisturize my
nostrils between a new job that requires
me to breathe in a lot of flour and
other powders and the air conditioning
as it is summer where I live my nostrils
have been quite dry recently is there a
safe and effective way for me to
moisturize them side note I have asthma
and thus cannot use humidifiers okay so
I want to just begin by acknowledging
the elephant in the room which is that
emily has essentially said without
saying it that she works in a cocaine
fact yeah I mean you can't just say
other powders that's not yeah I mean I
think we all know when you're talking
about flour and other powders you're
talking about mostly cocaine and then
secondarily the flour used to cut the
cocaine in potency I yes but first I
want to say Emily you should probably I
don't mean to judge but get another job
because working in a cocaine Factory is
both dangerous and illegal secondly
though yes I have the same problem and
there are a number of products on the
market that are specifically designed
for putting up your nose when it's dry
you can also according to a website I
went to use coconut oil which smells
good yeah the only thing that I would
say here Hank
is to make absolutely sure that if you
use water to use distilled water because
it's possible that if you use tap water
to moisturize your nostrils you could
get brain amoebas which are almost
always fatal yes and I do not want Emily
to get brain amoebas particularly given
that she is already taking so many risks
in her professional life yeah there's
the whole neti pot thing but there's
this stuff I use it's called air but it
spelled Ayr and there's a number of
similar products that it's just like a
saline gel it's saline solution yeah
yeah absolutely that's the solution and
I mean though the first solution is to
stop working in the cocaine factory but
if it's necessary to remain there then
yeah I think you
solution is a saline solution we want to
emphasize it's not a good idea to work
in a cocaine Factory it's just not a
good long-term no illusion mmm all right
John I've got another question from
David who asks dear Hank and John I
think I'm having a crisis in my life for
years I have always known what my
favorite colors are and I have always
been proud of that and never expected it
to change all of a sudden I find myself
admiring the color red and I'm afraid
it's replacing brown as my favorite
color
do I just abandoned brown and embrace
red and if I do
isn't that abandoning a part of who I am
please tell me what my favorite color
actually is so I can move on with my
life love David he didn't say love David
but I put that in there Hank
I've got great news for David and I
think that you're gonna agree with me on
this which is that David does not need
to change his favorite color due to the
fact that red is technically in my
opinion a shade of brown or is Brown a
shade of red no no no no no red is a
shade of brown for sure so your favorite
color is brown and your favorite shade
of brown at the moment is red but that
can evolve like the core essential thing
is that your favorite color is brown but
they're a bunch of shades of brown
you've got your your dark Browns your
white Browns your tans your Reds etc but
what if Brown is a shade of red and
David's favorite color was always red
and now he's just realizing it yeah no
that would make sense if Brown were a
shade of red unfortunately for you it's
not red is a shade of brown oh well I'm
so what other colors are shades of brown
yellow is yellow a shade of brown yellow
is is essentially a very light brown
that is correct so how about orange
orange also a shade of brown it's sort
of some would say in the same way that
red is a shade of brown yes orange is
definitely a shade of brown I'm gonna so
I'm gonna continue around the color
wheel and ask if if like blue is a shade
of brown good question
obviously not I mean look at blue it is
clearly not a shade of brown this is not
a difficult subject tank-like okay red
orange and yellow
Brown blue and green not shades of brown
black not a shade of brown white not a
shade of brown teal not a shade of brown
etc this is very obvious everyone knows
that red and yellow and oranges are
shades purple purple is not a shade of
brown it's between blue and green no
it's not it's between red and blue no
it's not it's between blue and green
maybe not on the color wheel but
everybody knows in real life like in
real you know the way we experience
colors it's between blue and green okay
do you have any more serious answers for
David I don't think it's that serious of
a question well you can say I would say
that that you are gonna change in your
life and you are going to abandon the
thing that you once were and you will no
longer be that thing and that is a sign
not of some personal disaster but of
growth and and and harkens back to our
our desire to write in your high school
yearbook
instead of don't ever change change I
mean I that's all lovely advice Hank and
it's a beautiful sentiment it's just
that as it happens his favorite color
has not changed okay all right all right
you got another question for us I have
another question but I I almost don't
want to move on until you acknowledge
that red is a shade of breath I'm going
to type it into Google is red a shade of
brown the first thought early I'm not
alone in thinking the autocomplete was
pink is red a shade of pink the color
[Laughter]
pink interestingly is not a shade of
brown but yeah oh I mean there's that
there's a Wikipedia page called shades
of brown and it isn't just yeah it's
amber beaver beige buff burnt sienna
burnt umber chestnut chocolate cocoa
brown deserts and khaki and you're still
in the seas Hank just scroll down to red
Peru
raw umber rosy Brown russet sandy brown
smokey topaz tan taupe and wood Maria
though that's the one it's it's russet
russet scent sandy brown that's that
they call that that's what some people
call red let's move on to another
question before I get proven wrong this
brush is from Trisha
okay who asks dear John and Hank you two
have established a few rules throughout
the podcast namely when one is allowed
to use the phrase turn of the century
and who gets which armrest and I've run
into another scenario that could use
your expertise at which point in the day
do I switch from saying have a good day
to have a good night
any dubious advice would be greatly
appreciated this is one of the great
questions I think of being alive the
first thing that I would say is I don't
know if you're familiar with Wheaton's
law it has a curse word in it so I don't
want to say it because my kid listens to
this podcast and presumably other kids
her but Wheaton's laws essentially don't
be a jerk right the other day I was on a
jog and I passed someone and you know
when you pass someone when you're
jogging you don't have a lot of time to
interact but you want to be polite so I
said morning I didn't say good morning I
just said morning as an acknowledgment
of a way of saying hello right also an
acknowledgement of the time of day it
was morning and the resident person is
like agreed it is that exactly so so the
way the conversation should go is you
say morning the other person says
morning or hello or whatever it is that
they want to say in this passing jogging
moment but what the person said instead
was it's 1202 are you a YouTube
commenter and I was like we don't have
time for me to pursue this conversation
further down the line because we are
passing each other while jogging you're
going seven miles an hour I'm going 5.2
miles per hour like the conversation is
about to end why did you need to do that
what did who who is the victor Wow oh
wow I love it I love it they love that
so much John you know I find it very
difficult to say the right thing in
these situation but when I'm saying like
when it's Friday and I'm saying goodbye
to someone a traditional thing to say is
have a nice weekend knowing that it is
Friday and that the weekend is coming up
is way beyond my cognitive ability like
I am so focused on just trying to have a
positive interaction with another human
knowing what day of the week it is is
way outside of my abilities so I like
it's funny you should mention that
because I'm actually strongly opposed to
have a good weekend oh yeah yeah because
so when Sarah and I first started dating
she managed an art gallery and her
working hours were Tuesday to Saturday
and in fact a lot of people's working
hours are not in traditional weekends
and when people would say on Friday
afternoon to Sarah have a good weekend
it was like a crushing attack it was
like a reminder that she had to go to
work at 7:30 in the morning on Saturday
oftentimes I'm saying this to people who
I employ and and who I am right
letting go for their time that they get
to have on their own so I do know what
their schedules are I think that
hopefully none of them worth the
weekends for other companies that that
would be I would be a lot of work but I
yeah and in the same way when you're at
a movie theater and they say enjoy the
movie and you're like you too because
like I don't know I don't know what I'm
saying
I can't control me and like the idea
that I'm gonna know whether it's have a
good day or have a good night I don't
know what time it is
I can't of the things that I'm trying to
deal with right now whether it's 4
o'clock or 6 o'clock is especially
during the summer in Montana when the
Sun Goes Down at like 9:30
you just no one knows no one knows what
time it is no one knows if it's day or
night
but I do have an opinion on this of
course you do the fact that you are
yourself totally unable to process any
such information doesn't keep you from
having a strong opinion absolutely well
it's not a strong opinion I think the
great thing about have a good day and
have a good night is that they overlap
significantly and you can actually have
you could say have a good day up to like
7 o'clock and you can si have a good
night anywhere after 5:00 I think you
can say have a good day as long as it is
still light and I think you can say have
a good night I agree starting at 5:00
p.m. so sometimes there's no crossover
like in winter in Indianapolis
you know
when the Sun sets at 4:45 that's one
thing but in summertime I agree you've
got have a good day as long as the Sun
is out and have a good night starting at
the end of the traditional workday 5:00
p.m.
agreed yeah yeah or I think I think that
if somebody's leaving work early you
could still say have a good night
because it's not like it's not like it
has to be night for them to have a good
one I'm wishing you a good night
whenever that occurs yeah so I think
we're settled there's a lot of overlap
and also we need in general to be
understanding of each other when it
comes to conversational slip-ups I mean
how does that person jogging even know
what time it is did they do they have
like a thing that says in their brain
like every time an hour like admit it
changes it's like it's 12:01 Jeremy its
1202 Jeremy it's not you know how you
have those little conversations with
strangers that stick with you for a long
long time because something some part of
it didn't go well I have a bunch of
those and you know you circle back to
them at night when you can't fall asleep
can I tell you another one it's really
it's super embarrassing okay so I have a
friend he's a journalist and he's
reporting on the New York Knicks and he
came to Indianapolis to watch a Knicks
game where they were playing the
Indianapolis Pacers my hometown NBA team
and he was like do you want to go to the
game and I was like sure and then after
the game he was like do you want to go
to the locker room and I was like yeah
and so I got to go to the locker room it
was really cool and it was a good
experience and when he gets to the
locker room you know there's all these
NBA players very large strong people and
lots of coaches and stuff and I noticed
that there was also a lot of food
specifically there was like some pulled
pork and rice and some food from local
restaurant and it was looked really good
and so I just grabbed a plate and I
started piling food onto my plate
because I was like you know whatever
free food and it turns out that food is
for the players so a guy comes up to me
and he says excuse me who are you and I
was like oh I'm John Green
[Applause]
and like I guess like that that line
doesn't go quite as far in the world of
the NBA as it might go you know other
places and and he is behind to me saying
I'm John Green was who is that and I was
like I'm with my friend and I named my
friend and he was like he was like and
and I was like and he said I could come
in here and he was like oh you can come
in here it's just that that food is for
the players and I was like who is that
who is that though oh and I essentially
every day in the years since that
happened to me I have spent at least 30
or 40 seconds
feeling regret about that whole
interaction well I'm glad to know that
about you I'm sorry that that happened
to you but we all have those moments
don't we except for me I don't hope that
we all have those moments I'm not alone
in this in this shame and horror anyway
Hank let's move on to another question
from our list all right this one's from
Kate who asks dear Hank and John I'm
currently watching the Olympic Swim
trials and wondering when you swim that
vigorously do you sweat like normal and
not notice it because the pool is
washing it off or does the pool cool you
down enough that you don't need to sweat
I'm hoping it's the latter because it
makes it less gross when they put the
water in their mouths oh I bet you sweat
you do sweat ah god I'm so good at
science tell me more
well yeah I mean it's very interesting
to like you can't notice that you're
sweating because there's no actual
physical sensation of like sweat came
out and now I feel that you feel the
sweat on you but if you're covered in
water then you don't feel the sweat so
yeah you do sweat and it's funny because
you're like technically your body
doesn't need to sweat because it's
obviously not gonna help you at all but
your body doesn't have any way of
knowing the trees your cut is submerged
in water so it still is like you are
hotter than you should be I will try to
cool you off and this is the technique I
have for trying to cool you off even
though it fails immediately so yeah you
sweat and swimming pools have sweat in
them
and when you put swimming pool water at
your mouth some of
sweat and it's okay except probably not
for John I mean it's not ideal for me
but I understand that I'm not coming at
it from a place of reason
let's move on to another question this
one's from Therese with the subject line
hope exists as a velociraptor Dear John
and Hank the school year has ended and
still I am wondering about a strange
rule my English teacher had according to
her the words is our was and were
provide no meaning and therefore should
be eliminated from language however I
think the phrase hope exists as the
thing with feathers does not have the
same ring to it as hope is the thing
with feathers
please help convince my teacher that the
words is our was and were our whoops not
the incarnation of evil itself
so Hank Oh God John John wait wait wait
wait you went for the science question
first so I wanna i want to have my go at
the grammar question okay
your teacher is dumb i think you mean
your teacher exists as an incorrect
thing in the world
sorry yes quite this see this seems this
seems ludicrous to me like deeply deeply
ludicrous especially for a for an
english teacher to say yeah i think i
know what's going on but i I strongly
agree with you that that it is ludicrous
now there are languages that do not have
those to be verbs in them it's just that
English is not one of them and and we
aren't we aren't going to change that
because so much of the way we
communicate involves to be verbs and
that's okay and it's not not the
incarnation of evil itself I think what
may be going on is that your teacher was
trying to discourage you or your fellow
students from using the passive voice in
your writing but that is not actually a
matter of removing all to be verbs from
your vocabulary it's just a matter of
using the passive voice hope is the
thing with feathers not an example of
the passive voice
so yeah your teacher is definitely 100%
wrong that that all all to be verb
should be removed from English at least
in my opinion and also I think in the
opinion of Emily Dickinson and really
I'm pretty sure every english-language
novel I've ever read but I also think by
the way that there are times when the
passive voice is perfectly justifiable
or even a good idea so yeah don't guy
yeah that's usually I fall I fall on the
side of English teachers especially when
it comes to students complaining that
reading a book critically is quote
killing it or destroying it for me or
whatever but in this case I have to side
with the student in favor of to be or
not to be but having some kind of to be
verb in your vocabulary
all right the ability to be I'm also in
favor of the ability to be John because
sometimes you stop being and that's
awful because it's that at the end then
you're just trying to work death back
into the podcast of the deceased it'd be
a comedy podcast about death but don't
worry I promise to work it in more
organically into the next question all
right John I look forward to you working
death into this question dear Hank and
John my friend and I recently got into a
debate about the correct way to wear a
wristwatch that was difficult to say I
argued that the face of the watch should
be on the top of the wrist she says that
it's easier to glance the face if it's
on the bottom of your wrist which is
correct is there a reason for wearing it
one way or the other it doesn't really
not matter at all John work death into
that one well I mean it doesn't matter
at all in the sense that you know
nothing that we do matters because you
know death is going to swallow all of us
in the end and everything that we do
will be forgotten by the sands of time
so I wouldn't spend too much time
thinking about your wristwatch being
this way or that when you know
ultimately to say that it isn't going to
matter is a dramatic understatement
because none of it's going to matter
right well I also agree that it doesn't
matter it's strange to me because I
never thought about it but yeah it does
seem a little more natural to look at
the inside of your wrist like in terms
of arm position it requires a little
less torque but I would also say that
most of the time the wristwatch is on
the top so that you know I think maybe
so that when you lay your arm down it
plays flat against a table because you
don't tend to lay your arm down with the
the top down and also if you have a
fancy watch you want people to see it
because you spent a lot of money on it
oh I thought the I thought the question
was should I put my watch upside down
because then I don't have good spatial
intelligence I don't really understand
this question I'm so like the person
looking at you can read it the person
standing in front of you can read her up
right-side up because that's definitely
that's exactly that's wrong about a
watch
I think it's like eating a Reese's I
don't really think there is necessarily
a wrong way to wear a watch although in
saying that I realize immediately that
there are a bunch of wrong ways to wear
a watch like for instance if you wear it
around your ankle right don't worry
round your ankle don't wear it on the
inside of your digestive tract that
would be bad oh man
that would be would be not ideal alright
Hank it's been a lot of fun and games
here let's tackle a serious question ok
this one comes from Maura WA who asks
Dear John and Hank what do you do when
you feel like you are not yourself like
you're watching your life play out in
hindsight or like you're watching a
movie and only finding out about the
decisions that quote-unquote you took
from the movie I know that sounds like
insanity but how do you stop yourself
thinking something when the thing you
want to stop and the thing you want to
stop it with are the same ah this is
actually I think a big fascinating
difficult question and something that I
struggle with all the time and that not
to spoil anything I'm writing about
everyday how do you even understand
yourself to be you or yours when you are
not in control of your thoughts or your
feelings or the actions of your body
like when you talk about you what do you
even mean
when the thoughts that are quote unquote
yours don't feel like they belong to you
or the body that his quote is quote
unquote yours doesn't feel like it
belongs to you like how do you how do
you make sense of that and I think the
only answer that I have is that it is
extremely complicated but that I don't
think it's uncommon to feel like you are
not in control of the thoughts that you
have been told are yours you know yeah I
we the the I have also been thinking a
lot about this interestingly I recently
gave a humorous talk but one of the one
of the I also like to like when I'm just
making jokes I like to mix in a little
bit of like oh I hadn't thought about
that before but there's that phrase I
think it's Victor Hugo nothing is as
powerful as an idea whose time has come
mm-hmm and I was talking about that
phrase and and the wonderful thing about
it is that it takes the agency out of
the people and it gives it to the idea
itself that gives us to this this
conception that yes requires a human
brain in order to express itself but has
power external to any individual human
and you cannot stop it in in the phrase
like it says on its own like the person
itself like the person having the idea
is not the powerful thing and indeed is
powerless next to the power of the idea
and I think that we have this myth in
our culture that we are all individuals
and that we make all of these decisions
and that we have this like and yes we do
make decisions and we do construct
ourselves but to some extent like we are
very much a product of the things that
we you know have been told and consumed
and and the people in our lives and and
we all construct that for each other and
I think it's I find it helpful to
recognize that that is a thing and that
I am not just me I am a creation that
has I'm the creation that that I that
like my consciousness has been involved
in creating but that has also been
created by all of the things that I have
consumed in all of the people that I
have known and and and by you know my
parents and the people that I love
yeah it's they're very much
both and proposition to me consciousness
in general that consciousness is both
something that is within and something
that is without and it's almost like for
me at least like in accepting that
there's a measure of freedom there's
also I mean I want to emphasize that you
know both Hank and I come at this from a
very like thinking about consciousness
from a very particular and and in like
lots and lots of different ways very
privileged position but but for me being
able to to say I'm not in control of
these thoughts and I don't want to be
having them
he is very McKnight is a kind of
empowering for me that way I don't have
to be held responsible for every thought
that comes across my bow you know and in
the times in my life when I felt like I
did have to be responsible for every
thought that came across my bow it was
very difficult because a lot of times I
don't like the thoughts that I'm having
or I don't feel like I'm in control of
them and you know I think for me at
least like acknowledging like yes I am
an individual but I am also like within
a big complicated endless nexus of
cultures and consciousnesses that are
all interacting both inside of me and
outside of me there was there there's
some freedom in that and it also makes
me feel a little bit less less like I'm
you know crazy for lack of a better term
but yeah I also I mean look if you if
you feel it if you start to feel like
you're really a not in control of of
your consciousness or your thoughts or
your feelings the other thing that I
would say is that it's important to talk
about that with somebody who's
professional and who knows a lot more
about that than Hank or John so I think
that's the other thing that's been
helpful in my own life when I've when I
felt like that as I often do excellent
I have another question that I really
want to get to because I think that it's
important and I am an expert
on this it's from River who asks dear
Hank and John I live on the southwest
coast of Oregon and since I was young
I've been told to be prepared for the
big one which is a large earthquake that
we are overdue for this would also cause
a devastating tsunami my question is if
I happen to be walking along the beach
when this earthquake strikes should I
swim out far into the ocean before the
tsunami strikes assuming that I have no
chance of reaching higher ground should
I accept my watery demise or attempt to
avoid the tsunami much like boats do by
sailing out into the ocean River do not
swim out into the ocean
I have a one-sentence piece of advice
when the tsunami is coming do not
attempt to swim two miles out into the
ocean and then swim yeah there there so
if you feel the earthquake and I do want
to give you this advice to everyone in
the coast of the Pacific Northwest or
anywhere where there may be a tsunami
you have anywhere from five to thirty
minutes to get to a safe place
you do not know how long it's gonna take
so it is perfectly possible that you
could walk at a leisurely pace up a hill
and survive you don't not know how big
the tsunamis gonna be you do not know
how long it's gonna take to get there
you don't know if there's gonna be a
tsunami at all but if you see if you
feel an earthquake and you're walking
along a beach you go will climb up that
hill and you do it now so Hank when
River says that the big one is overdue
and is coming any day is that true well
it depends on what you mean by any day
but yes there will be some day another
very large earthquake that hits the
Pacific Northwest and there hasn't been
one in a very very long time and in the
geological record so when you say very
large you mean like terrifying really
bad yeah going large worse than
Hurricane Katrina bad oh Jesus
and and it will be very very bad and and
you know the people in the Pacific
Northwest are working on systems to make
it less bad and but like there are a lot
of people who live in the tsunami zone
and it will be very bad
so no your evacuation routes and and
know where the the nearest highest
ground is and head there and
and if you're if you get stuck in
traffic get out and walk okay so today's
podcast is brought to you no joke by
Hanks disaster preparedness plan Hank's
disaster preparedness plan do not swim
out into the ocean seek high ground
immediately Hank is not kidding he is
very serious about this this is not a
joke
yeah okay I agree I was recently in
Oregon and I was walking along the beach
and I was like boy if I the other thing
to know is if you see the water getting
sucked out like suddenly water stay
you're like why is suddenly the water
all gone that's a very bad sign and you
should climb a tree because you do not
have a lot of time so as I just did some
time in Oregon recently and I always
think about tsunamis when I'm on that
Coast
oh man who's the one who's preoccupied
with apocalyptic worry used to be me but
the shoe is suddenly on the other foot
Hank who else has brought us the podcast
today of who the podcast was also
brought to you by the the sweat in the
swimming pool a good old fashioned
swimming pool sweat it's in there
delicious not even to mention the pee
which is also in there and of course
today's podcast is brought to you by
shades of brown shades of brown now
including red and yellow and orange
delicious orange and finally this
podcast is brought to you by other kinds
of powders other kinds of powders
definitely not a euphemism for working
in a cocaine factory good old other
powders what's the other powder what
what is I mean I'm trying to imagine an
on cocaine factory explanation for
Emily's life right imagine that Emily it
works in a bakery and that there's
cornstarch and that there's powdered
sugar and that cornstarch is not a
powder and powdered sugar is not really
a powder I mean it's in the name John I
don't know
I'm very concerned about the size the
dirty sugar it is definitely a powder I
mean if there is anything that I cannot
imagine I am NOT gonna let you get away
with that there is nothing more powdered
powder like than powdered sugar I don't
know why I got so angry okay Hank before
we get to the all-important news from
Mars
the news from ANSI Wimbledon which I
would just assume skip to be honest with
you let's get to a few responses from
previous episodes the first most
important thing I want to risk that one
one one thing we've gotten a number of
responses from is current employees of
Amazon several of them have written in
to talk about how Jeff Bezos is indeed
not referred to as a colleague or as a
co-worker but as Jeff for instance this
letter came in from Mark in your latest
episode you talked about how everyone at
Amazon would probably call Jeff Jeff
well I've worked at Amazon for more than
three years and can confirm that this is
exactly the case so much so that I've
been on a team where people called Jeff
Bezos Jeff and refer to the Jeff who
works ten feet away by using his first
and last name oh man it's hard out there
for the other Jeff's
another response from Jamaal who says
I'm active duty Navy and currently
stationed in Japan there is an abundance
of zimas here since Hank is such a
vehement fan I'm currently working out
the legalities of international
shipments of alcohol to Montana what
address can I send them to Jamaal that's
a great question in an extremely
important one mostly because I want to
see how Hank actually feels about Zima
especially if you can manage to send 378
of them from Japan by the way I will be
more than happy to reimburse you for
those 378 x'mas unfortunately our only
address is a peel box because otherwise
you'd have to send it to our house
however I'm going to let you know what
our p.o box is it is p.o box three zero
one five two indianapolis indiana four
six two three zero and you can press
that to John Green or to Hank green or
just to Zima lovers everywhere
I'm surprised to know you can't send 378
x'mas from a Navy base in Japan to
Indianapolis that just doesn't seem
right yeah the the logistics John
logistics so we have an actual PPO box
is what you're saying to me right we do
we have an actual p.o box where you can
send us 378 of anything please no less
and also no more peal box three zero one
five two indianapolis indiana force
to 3-0 speaking of which we heard from a
listener named Rachel who used to live
outside of the big league two factory or
something like that or her friend does
and they have and they like give out if
you like knock on the door of the big
league to factory they give out big Li
to rejects and so John you said you
wanted 378 packets of big league -
apparently rachel has the inside track
on that so Rachel hey Rachel if you can
hook me up I would be very very grateful
I can't tell you how much I enjoy big
league Jew or at least how much I
enjoyed it when I last tried it in 1985
yeah I think that I think that we can
say - Rachel absolutely if you also want
to send us a bill for the shipping we'll
handle it for you yes correct although I
don't want to go down the road Hank of
offering to pay for 378 anything's
because it seems like a dangerous
dangerous game all right one last
response this one came in from Annie who
wrote I have an idea for the listener
who wondered what to do with her middle
school writings when I was a senior in
college my roommate and I joked about
how terribly we'd written when we were
younger and we pulled up essays we'd
turned in as freshmen and laughed
uproariously at the quality of our work
which gave us the idea for the greatest
party ever
we held a middle school poetry slam and
asked our friends to bring their
favorite and/or worst writings from when
they were younger that is indeed a
wonderful and I think that's that's one
to hold on to that's a great idea I love
that I think we should do that on the
vlogbrothers Channel mmm no I'm gonna
argue against that let's move on to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank I
should probably go first we'll get this
over as fast as possible AFC Wimbledon
are three games into their league one
season they have won no games but also
they have tied no games that's not good
it's not good it's not going great we
just lost a Scunthorpe
also lost to bolton and before that lost
to Walsall also lost to Peterborough in
the Football League Cup which is a
separate competition so we're out of
that competition for game so far this
season
zero points sitting last in the league
one table now one could argue that the
three teams that have beaten us are all
in the top seven of the league one table
alternately one could argue that one of
the reasons they're in the top seven is
because they've all played AFC Wimbledon
a very very nervous start to the season
here one piece of comfort if we just won
one of those three games we would be
sitting 14th but we didn't so we're
sitting in last mm-hmm I'm sorry that
does not sound great well life is long
and so is a season he said vaguely
hopeful what's the news from Mars and
and also a little worried you're gonna
have to go through a whole season of
this what's the news from Mars
alright the news from Mars is that
getting to Mars is hard the trip that
we've done one long-term fairly
long-term trip to another place and that
was to the moon and you can do that in a
little box because it's just a few days
to get there so they the people who
enter the moon they just sat in that
basically the little thing that they
shot them up on the rocket with but you
cannot do that to Mars because it takes
at minimum six months to get there and
then another six months to get back so
you need space you need space for
astronauts to move around to do their
research to exercise and also to store
all the stuff that they need so nASA has
just launched the next step to program
which asks six different companies to
design and prototype deep-space habitats
and they have budgeted I think 65
million dollars to divide amongst these
companies to design those habitats each
company's each company has a different
set of skills so each habitat will have
different capabilities and usefulness is
a Bigelow Aerospace for example
specializes in lightweight inflatable
habitats so they can like launch up this
thing and then just fill it with air and
it becomes you know a place where people
can spend some time and one of those was
recently tested on the Internet
Space Station so it's a thing that works
so if we ever want to get to Mars we
need a place to live in while we're
going there and NASA has taken a big
step in that direction to get us there
before 2028 that was a terrible bad yeah
and you sound about as confident in
getting there before 2028 as I sound
about AFC Wimbledon season at the moment
hard times for lovers of Mars and or the
world's greatest third tier soccer team
but you know hope is the thing with
feathers or hope exists as the thing
with feathers it does it exists that way
think what did we learn today Jon we
learned that well I learned that you
shouldn't use a humidifier if you have a
smell which is a thing I didn't yeah
that's that's helpful I also learned
that the US Mint does not make any
hundred-dollar bills or for that matter
any bills they only make coins which is
why they are called a mint maybe I could
have put that together myself you would
think no no I needed help we also
learned that that apparently there are
many many many shades of brown and no
shades of red
they're all just shades of brown no
there are many shades of red there just
fall within the larger category of brown
and we learned that Zima still exists in
Japan which fills me with hope that one
day Hank will be forced to drink 378
x'mas to try to prove that he actually
likes Zima only to find out that in fact
he doesn't and of course we learned that
despite the fact that neither of us care
or are able to implement this advice as
long as the Sun is up you could say have
a good day and anytime after 5:00 you
could say have a good night not almost
say anytime after 4:00 I know I know I
think it's it's very fluid and there's a
lot of overlap and I just think that no
one should no one should cause any
ruckus either way because it's very hard
to keep all this stuff straight John
it's too much it's just so hard to be a
human let's just try whenever possible
to be careful of each other and kind to
each other
unless it's 1202 in which case you gotta
say it's it's 1202 other restraints are
running still it still bugs me but I'm
glad it now bugs you as well thanks
to everyone who listen to our podcast by
the way you can go to our patreon
patreon comm slash dear Hank and John if
you want to support this podcast
directly and thanks as always to my
actual corporate sponsor
Snickers you can say that you can say I
guess you can say that I guess you
should aletan they're still eating those
free Snickers hoping that there's more
on the way but yeah thanks for listening
Nicholas Jenkins edited Espada cast
Claudia Morales is our intern rosianna
halse rojas helped us out with the
questions our theme music is by the
great gunnarolla check out his YouTube
channel or any of his songs and Hank did
I miss anything no I think you got
everything oh where will our email
address our email addresses is Hank and
John at gmail.com you can email us your
questions you can also send them to us
on Twitter where John is John Green and
I am Hank green I'm also on snapchat
it's hank GRE and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]